nowadays there are competitions out
there that challenge you to make a short
film over the course of just one weekend
they're really fun way to gain
experience network and create a film
quickly very quickly last year I entered
my first timed competition and the short
film I wrote placed first out of 58
total films I met Marcia Gay Harden I
got into variety and I was even invited
by my team to compete for a second and
third time writing films that ranked
among the very best today I'm going to
teach you what I've learned from my
experiences to bypass the competition
and get you into the cream of the crop
the first thing you got to know is for
these challenges the shorts are due on
Sunday which means you really only have
Friday to work on the story and deliver
a script in addition to that the
competition wants to make sure that you
don't start any earlier so they give you
a specific list of requirements on
Friday that must be present in your film
my first piece of advice is to split
these requirements up ignore minor
requirements like props or dialogue and
start with the one that matters the most
genre genre is going to be your compass
pointing your story in the right
direction you need to deconstruct that
genre and figure out what that genre is
really all about on a subatomic level
for example we were given the fantasy
genre for our second film crystals ball
after researching examples online I
noticed that many fantasy stories follow
a similar structure a character has some
sort of pain enters this sort of
Fantasyland to escape that pain but it's
not all peaches and cream there and the
character eventually returns to the real
world with a new outlook from the entire
experience and that's what we ended up
doing we told a story about a grieving
daughter that uses a crystal ball to
reunite with her dead father but if
their reunion is not all peaches and
cream and near the end of the film she
leaves and is a tad different from where
she started
after breaking down your genre into its
most basic form you should then consider
the two big assets you'll be working
with actors and location because time
was of the essence for our films both
the actors and the locations were
already set each time before the story
was even conceived that's actually okay
since those two factors along with an
understanding of the genre are a great
launching point for brainstorming my
first suggestion for generating ideas is
to zero in on conflict conflict is the
lifeblood of any story even a short one
told in just a few minutes what might
help you get into this conflict mindset
is to just casually think about what a
potential problem could be when you
factor in both your actors and your
location and then after that a potential
solution when you've come up with some
possibilities I'd suggest you start your
story with the problem that excites you
the most that being said my second
suggestion
during this stage is to keep it simple
you don't have hours to tell your story
only minutes and you don't have much
time to write it out either you can be
more detail-oriented later in the
process but probably won't do you any
favors to do so at the very start what
may help with simplicity is to think of
your story in threes take a step back
look at the big picture and try to
describe your stories beginning middle
and end in the most simplistic way for
example before writing our first film
checkmate we had a house as our location
and four actors cast already so zeroing
in on the conflict the problem that was
the most exciting was about the house
having a vacancy and two of our actors
fighting over it
meanwhile the other two actors became
the ones who already lived there so then
expanding that premise into threes the
two actors meet at the house in the
beginning of the story they fight over
the vacancy in the middle and then they
quickly become friends and decide to
room together by the end they meet they
fight they become friends simple
when you figured out the simple
beginning middle and end of your story
you could just jump into writing the
first draft of the script or what I
recommend is to take another writing
step in between and write out a brief
synopsis of your story in just a couple
of paragraphs by doing so it gives you
another opportunity to rewrite your
story in a new format and do so quickly
also a brief synopsis is going to be a
tad more detailed so here you're going
to want to add in the lesser
requirements from the competition
requirements like what props to put in
or what dialogue to say will be easier
to plug in to your story now that you
already have the backbone for your story
figured out if you're with another
writer or the director at this stage
this is your chance to pitch them with
your synopsis and get them on board with
your story before you flesh it out in
script format especially if you or
someone else is not quite sold on the
idea yet here you can get feedback
regarding what you need to improve on or
you can get confidence with what's
working with your story
with all that very loose planning done
and all your thinking power focused on
what assets you have and what
requirements you need to check off you
can now focus on writing your story out
in script format I use final draft but
really any screenwriting software out
there should help you create your final
version as quickly as possible for this
last step
I'd suggest pulling up your synopsis and
then quickly writing out a script
version of it that you'll probably think
is bad also I would restrain yourself
from making any edits to it until you've
finished writing this bad draft but keep
in mind even though you've already done
a bunch of planning this is still your
very first draft of the script it's
supposed to be rough and unpolished so
don't beat yourself up over the quality
just focus on converting your synopsis
into a bad draft first and then after
you're done with that step look at it
with a critical eye and make some edits
for your final draft
so my first and third films I did for a
competition were for the Easter Seals
disability film challenge which was
amazing to be a part of disability is
very much underrepresented and
misrepresented in the media and being a
part of the challenge helped to move the
needle when it came to that the
competition welcomes all filmmakers who
are down with that cause and down to
make something really quick so now that
I've given you some tips on how to write
for a timed competition I hope you'll
consider joining that one and making an
impact as well if you want to check it
out or any of the films please see the
links in the description below
good luck and I'll see you next time on
film courage